Ronaldo the Ronaldo went to Saudi Arabia
Ronaldo so Ronaldo with Saudi Arabia
yeah that sucks uh no sad dude sad crazy
only 75 million a year I thought you're
supposed to get 275 million dollars did
you get up to 200 million in a year but
I don't know how yeah that's the report
but still what are you doing man yeah
this is a sad way to go they validate my
friend said this to me he goes uh
players validate themselves by the
offers they get
so
you know you're getting contracts you're
still the guy you're still the man and
he's not getting offers from any of the
other major clubs it seems a lot of the
Premier League teams don't want to order
them oh like he got offers from or like
he talked to different teams and they
were like oh yeah we're trying to build
around this guy and you're only going to
be here for another year so to basically
sideline everything we've been building
for the last three years to try to work
you into our system for then you to
retire after a year or two is not
working because he doesn't want to play
a part of the system he's a bum he wants
to be the guy yeah he's just not good
enough to be the guy at that that level
anymore and if he's gonna retire in a
year or two it's like we're going to do
all this work to build his team around
you and you might not even be worth the
investment to build a team around he was
saying he was talking to Brazilian teams
Portuguese teams American teams which
U.S team wouldn't do it just for two
years of marketing that's different I
think what we're talking about is
competing at is still a high level in
one of the top four leagues so now he's
like okay if I'm not going to compete at
the highest level what's going to make
me the most money yeah and it looks like
you can't compete with Saudi yeah in the
offers
um but what my buddy was saying is that
that's what the athletes tend to do is
they value date themselves by the
contracts they're getting and that was
the biggest contract so in his mind he
can still be the biggest player yep
probably wasn't getting offered close to
that from American team maybe he would
have gotten like a percentage of the
club or something like that but I can
imagine that this Saudi deal is even if
they say it's 75 million maybe like
listen we can only say 75 because we
might want to lure other players
eventually and we don't want to pay them
this so we'll give you this on the side
like the crown owns all the money right
they can give you whatever the [ __ ] they
want yeah percent of jerseys or this
house you get this land whatever so
it's a bummer because it could have been
really cool as soccer is exploding in
America we have the World Cup coming
here there's the most interest in our
lives we've ever seen in soccer and then
you have arguably the most famous soccer
player on the planet comes to America
with the other most famous it would be
the perfect time yeah for Messi Ronaldo
to come to America and then soccer
become like the second most popular
sport in America the third most popular
sport you're a football basketball
soccer I would be awesome yeah and uh he
you know he followed the money and you
can't fault him for that he has every
right to make as much fun as he wants
but uh yeah it's a it's a bummer
because he it feels like he missed out
on like a cool cultural play yeah actual
question someone who doesn't know soccer
it seems like the Messi Ronaldo debate
is pretty over yeah I mean it's crazy if
you ask someone in like 2018 and you're
like okay imagine these two goats are
going at it Messi wins the World Cup and
then Ronaldo can't find a team to play
with and then goes to play in Saudi
Arabia people be like this is insane did
he get injured like it's like
incomprehensible it seems like within
the past 30 days or whatever the World
Cup fine two weeks the conversation yeah
the conversation's over yeah like
imagine in two years like Steph Curry
can't find a team it has to go to like
turkey yeah it's like how could that
even happen yeah it's crazy yeah yeah
it's uh so he declined that much
I don't like I think it's partially his
he wanted to be the guy yeah I think
it's a little it's a decline but also
you're not willing to be you don't want
to be a role player and maybe his skill
set
isn't built around being a role player
like for example Steph Curry could play
in the NBA until he's 50 years old
because he can stand in the corner and
hit threes 10 minutes a game if you need
him he can find the open guy yeah and
he's not gonna take a pickup well we're
talking about Ronaldo so Ronaldo's going
on my team pay rep because again he's
validating himself through the money
it's a weird thing that happens but my
buddy works in supports is basically
like it's just over this amount of time
that's how you start to identify your
status in the world yeah you don't want
to think you're going down exactly I've
also heard part of the reason there's
holdouts and agents probably play a role
in this but like a player won't think
I'm worth 100 million necessarily what
he'll think is if this guy got 98
million I'm better than that guy I get
100. it's not about the money it's about
the competition even with it doesn't
matter where the money is coming from
like if you're not in not in one of the
Premier Leagues not when you're
convincing yourself yeah he's I think
he's in a little bit of denial probably
yeah because listen he gets benched for
Portugal
they get booted he doesn't have a great
cup yeah doesn't play well man you has
issues with the club they like kind of
oust him he like talks [ __ ] about them
I'm not playing well it's never him
right yeah he's upset at Portugal he's
upset at menu he's always upset and this
is
classic right it's like classic what
happens to a lot of star players who are
just like
you know his the resilience the mental
resilience that he has that gets him
here is also the thing that's going to
inhibit him from realizing that he's
fallen it becomes stubbornness after a
while yeah but this spin cycle seems
pretty short relative to what he's done
so far that it's pretty unfortunate that
that it puts you in that place so
quickly in the end I mean I think it's
expedited by the messy situation right
like a Messi's meteoric rise to the
number one football player in the world
without a question just beloved beloved
and like everything about his attitude
his demeanor the fact that he's not loud
the fact that he's like he's got his
girl he's known since he's 12. it's like
the perfect [ __ ] story physically
small like he was Underdog the run to
became a hero like universally liked by
his teammates it seems pays for the
whole [ __ ] the Argentine team like
they're going through financial
hardships apparently he paid for
everybody on the team's salaries yeah
like one year so like they're like all
these crazy cool stories are coming out
that he's just like a great guy and uh
and then poor Ronaldo is like the Brash
bravado strong
cocky take your shirt off yeah Gaston
like yeah literally he's the guy most of
her heroes are and Messi is the guy you
wish most of your Heroes were yeah well
I I would I would I would make the
argument that Messi is actually the
David character
in typical like Hero Stories like it is
the guy who's smaller he's he's yeah
where Ronaldo is the Goliath yeah yeah
or the Gaston yeah so it's like he's the
person in the the fairy tale that like
that should be the The Prince and the
fairy tale that ends up not marrying the
princess and then the the weak Boy ends
up proving that he is the you know the
true Suiter that's crazy yeah I'm just
curious if it's a good investment for on
this year
so like the amount that they spent how
would they justify that would it just be
through oh [ __ ] like brand recognition
to Saudi would it be through like jersey
sales would have like I'd saw their
instrument followers I think they got
like 5 million overnight yep from like
the announcement yep so and like even
those stats alone I wonder if that would
be beneficial for them even like
streaming rights like how much value
does a player like that so so here are
the things one
Saudi Arabia doesn't give a flying [ __ ]
about making money on any of these other
endeavors okay this is all marketing
come to Saudi Arabia we're going to run
out of oil eventually we need to prove
to you that there's some [ __ ] here
besides oil Derricks and Mecca because I
think the average person in the world
just goes I think all Saudi Arabia has
is oil Derricks and Mecca yeah so oh
well we have a whole football league I
didn't even know Saudi Arabia had a
football I didn't know until Ronaldo
yeah so uh Saudi Arabia just built this
hotel the habitats or something like
that it's near Jordan and a part of
Saudi Arabia that some of the Jordan the
the the the the geology looks just like
Jordan that's like built within these
like crazy like rock structures and they
just spent like 10 times what another
hotel another habitas hotel would ever
spend and it's simply just to draw
tourists out there to prove that they
have more than oil Derricks and Mecca
they're building the hold up the lines
like Wadi Rum and you go exactly they're
building the line City for the same
reason right the lion City exactly so
all these things are like marketing how
can we become like this global Global
City and how can we shed a little bit of
the represent the representation of the
reputation the stigma that we already
have which is like hey women can't drive
everybody you know birken up to here
khashoggi okay that's 100 million
dollars uh right there so if the world
is watching Saudi football games not the
world but like you know the Ronaldo fans
are watching Saudi football fans maybe
they want to go to Saudi to watch a
football fan now there's an excuse now
there's an excuse to travel a little bit
right like and people will go do that
yeah they're Ronaldo fans like dude if
Michael Jordan was playing in another
[ __ ] country you don't think that
Michael Jordan fans would go there and
watch a game 100 so will they make back
the 275 million dollars like dollar per
dollar I don't know but
is there a it is an infinite amount of
money that is returned from viewing
Saudi Arabia as more than just those two
things yeah right and all these oil Rich
Middle Eastern companies are now
investing in other things because they
know the oil's time is limited so their
money from all the oil is making money
even when it all dries up it's gonna be
do whatever the word is Diversified into
so many things they're always going to
have like infinite money so I can pay 75
million who gives a [ __ ] if it gives me
good PR yeah that Golf League I don't
think you're making money on that oh
yeah the live golf the live golf another
one they're just throwing crazy bread at
it see us differently see us as you that
term everyone's using is sports washing
Sports watching
like money laundering but through Sports
yeah exactly yeah like you can clean up
the reputation of your country through
having some big sporting event Olympics
whatever yeah but this is I saw this is
funny this is the coach of almost here
the base was like Cristiano I wanted to
bring Messi first
and as like a joke during the press
conference and he was like I'm just
joking but it's like the fact that he's
even bringing it up is like another nail
in the coffin That's like [ __ ] up his
reputation his legacy wow again I think
his legacy is going to be whatever top
five ever or whatever it is not gonna be
that hurt in the long run but right now
yeah this pin it was but to go from one
to five yeah that's not great yeah you
know you don't think he'll be two
I think we no Pele and then uh well I
mean if you're if you're going off of
World Cups it's Paley
yeah Baylor has three World Cups yeah
that's the most remarkable competitive
feat I've ever seen in the history of
sports
three World Cups yeah you're the best
player on the team for all three yeah
didn't you saying both have like three
12 years in a row three goals in the 100
meter dash is okay also pretty [ __ ]
crazy but what doesn't it I'm saying
Julius Irving with 11 or how many yes
Russell yeah so the thing about Bill
Russell is far fewer teams I don't know
I think that I think black people like
weren't even playing in the NBA do you
know what I mean I'm not trying to
diminish what he did he's with the
greatest winner in the history of
basketball there's no doubt but
but for me
one person affects a soccer match much
less than one person affects a
basketball game and the fact that he
could be the best player
on the team
for three World Cups and win three
that's a 12-year period
like that's nuts yeah it's crazy so I
can understand why people make that
argument then there's the Maradona
argument but like so nobody's coming
close to him what's the next I mean is
it does anybody else have two
World Cups oh maybe I don't know I think
Ronaldo actually no no oh the OG Ronaldo
oh
new Ronaldo he goes there's only one
Ronaldo
and that [ __ ] Ronaldo
bro yeah I completely forgot about him
oh no he's all right well he had that
little patch in the front remember yeah
yeah yeah yeah but um but yeah so what
do you think happens in like his first
League or his first season with the
league who Ronaldo yeah I mean I think
that'll play incredibly well and he'll
you know score and he'll do everything
that they want him to do will it be that
relevant though and this is different
probably but Beckham came to La I
remember the Galaxy I lived in La the
time huge deal but very quickly we
stopped giving a [ __ ] I mean very
quickly and I even if he was good I
don't know did they win a championship
MLS Cup I don't know globally his
relevance maintained just through his
marriage and his ads or whatever but
could Ronaldo's relevance decrease
especially as a soccer player yeah I was
thinking that because like Andreas
Iniesta one of the greatest players I've
ever played for Barca forever played
with Messi like [ __ ] one of the best
like Center mids ever now is playing in
a Japanese league and I didn't even know
he's playing a Japanese yeah he got like
30 million or something like that yeah
it was great money to go and play this
Japanese but I was like I've never seen
a highlight Japanese but love his game
yeah that is the perfect player to go
play in Japan yeah yeah just pure
technical yeah greatness like they don't
want Ronaldo jumping around he's just
like hard worker yeah he just gets it
done but I'm like yeah I I haven't seen
any highlights from him playing in Japan
I haven't seen anything come out I
thought he retired yeah I thought he
retired also I just don't remember what
happened to him I just got sad about
this like whenever I guess it's 75
million but whenever an NBA player is
like playing in China it's always kind
of sad like imagine [ __ ] LeBron in
six years playing in Tokyo you'd be like
ah this is painful to watch yeah a
billion people it's a little at least
they're gonna watch it in in Arabic it's
something to cheer on and say okay let's
develop soccer I'm sure it's a little
different please explain how because
it's it's a little different because
when an American player goes to a league
abroad they're not making the money that
they would make fair enough yeah and
when these guys go to leagues abroad
they're actually making more and they
would make at the person I think even if
LeBron was getting 100 million from
China we'd be like
come on I don't know about that
you ain't watching a game oh I'm not
watching a single game but wait I would
watch it there's a Veronica's a bunch of
Chinese dudes that'd be [ __ ] awesome
but there is a number though that's
interesting that you say that because if
he's making like 10 million to go over
there I'm like oh man he needs money
something's wrong with him financially
but if he was making 275 or whatever the
[ __ ] amount was announced with this
Cristiano deal like if he was making
money that he was never even close to
making per year playing in with the
Lakers or something like that I'd be
like okay I could see why you do that
and I think LeBron would I think LeBron
will go to China and play for 275
million a year